razones concretas han llevado a la OMS a
seguir manteniendo la emergencia
sanitaria Gracias Rodrigo muy amable
Buenas tardes primero tenemos que
considerar el constante incremento de
casos que se ha venido viendo así como
de fallecidos Si vemos aunque haya
habido en los últimos 28 Días un ligero
descenso de casos en los mismo periodo
ha habido un incremento de mortalidad
esto quiere decir que las variantes
nuevas que están apareciendo de omicron
siguen siendo altamente contagiosas y
están afectando principalmente a los no
vacunados con hospitalizaciones y
fallecimientos mientras se mantenga
estos millones de casos activos en el
mundo obviamente la OMS no va a bajar la
guardia ni va a bajar la declaratoria de
emergencia
durante muchos meses también se habló
del desigual reparto de las vacunas y se
crearon organismos como el covax para
intentar revertir esa desigualdad se ha
conseguido esta meta en realidad no creo
que uno de los grandes problemas que
tuvimos es de que el mecanismo covax iba
a depender de que la OMS aprobara las
vacunas Porque siendo un mecanismo
vinculado al sistema de Naciones Unidas
dependía de que la OMS declarara las
vacunas como precalificadas para
poderlas distribuir como la OMS Se tardó
un poco más en esta de en esta
aprobación las empresas con la
aprobación de la Ema de Europa y la fda
de Estados Unidos lo que hicieron fue
empezar a hacer acuerdos bilaterales con
países lo cual distorsionó el mercado
global dejando a covax sin vacunas
cuando estas fueron aprobadas Entonces
los mercados se fueron hacia lo privado
con Los acuerdos bilaterales que muchos
países firmaron Canadá Estados Unidos
México Brasil Colombia firmaron algunos
acuerdos y los países europeos por su
lado y algunos otros países que tenían
la disponibilidad de recursos económicos
para hacerlo dejando a los países menos
favorecidos con menos acceso a las
vacunas ahora bien las vacunas han ido
evolucionando como ha venido
evolucionando las variantes entonces las
primeras vacunas que se vieron al inicio
ya no son tan efectivas como son las
últimas vacunas que sacaron en Estados
Unidos con las dos variantes de omicron
señor Becerra qué se necesitaría ahora
para que se declarara por fin el fin
total de la pandemia Y qué mecanismos se
han implantado para evitar futuros casos
como este yo creo que primero los países
tendrán que seguir tomando las medidas
necesarias y nosotros como ciudadanos
hacer lo que les corresponde seguirnos
cuidando utilizar los cubrebocas en
espacios públicos abiertos y cerrados y
sobre todo en transporte público y en
avión por otro lado
la vigilancia epidemiológica por parte
de los gobiernos es muy importante y
tener conscientes de que una pandemia de
este tipo puede volver a suceder con
cualquier otro cualquier otro patógeno
Entonces los países tienen que
prepararse mucho para estar preparados y
no tener una un enfrentamiento que nos
agarre con una mano delante y otra atrás
como decimos vulgarmente porque este
tipo de situaciones va a volver a
suceder esta semana es crítica Rodrigo
porque inicia el consejo ejecutivo de la
OMS donde se muchos de estos temas y se
pone la agenda para la asamblea
sanitaria mundial que es en mayo al
mismo tiempo otro hoyito es el cambio de
director en el organismo regional la Ops
toma posesión al doctor Barbosa el día
de mañana y tenemos todo este tipo de
situaciones que suceden en una semana de
conmemoración de los tres años la
asamblea el que se pone la agenda para
la asamblea Mundial de la Salud cambio
de nuevo director en la Ops y los países
tienen que seguir preparándose para una
pandemia que pudiera suceder en
cualquier momento